quand le papier glacé s'invite à la
bibliothèque à paris une exposition à la
bnf retrace en photos l'histoire d'un
des plus célèbres magazines de mode
vogue créée en 1920 à l'occasion de
suivre l'évolution de la mode mais aussi
des modes de vie des femmes pendant
presque un siècle marie bérurier loïc le
moigne c'est la rencontre des quatre
tours et du glamour
un vrai choc des cultures entre la star
des magazines de mode et la grande
bibliothèque
aujourd'hui volg a presque son temps et
à la bnf ces photos ultra travaillée
prennent une autre dimension
voguez touchera les plus grands
photographes
donc on a des archis absolument
exceptionnelle man ray ou erwin
blumenfeld c'était s'il ya 80 ans et ces
femmes là n'ont pas l'air d'avoir pris
une ride
tous ses tics artistique piqué au
surréalisme annonce la femme moderne à
une entrée de la femme dans l'espace
public
elle travaille elle immobile elle est
susceptible de changement et donc ça
impose des corps qu'ils soient beaucoup
plus fluide beaucoup plus léger et
beaucoup plus tonique aveugle les années
60-70 ce sont des années culte et les
années 80 les idées lithiques qu on vous
pique quand vous regardez même nous aux
deux autres magazines de mode c'est une
référence et tout le monde tout le monde
tout le monde se réfère à ces années je
pense que années 70 à 85 c les années
les plus copiés même aujourd'hui tout le
monde copie
je pense qu'on va guetter assez
innovateur en fait aux est sans doute
plus de choses que d'autres magazines à
l'époque dans les locaux papier glacé du
magazine
l'objectif reste le même aujourd'hui une
espèce d'ébullition mag et d'émulation
magazine ans possédant les autres on
aime beaucoup cette provocation
provocation élégante mais c'est de faire
la beauté qui marque qui rêve
c'est un évent a aujourd'hui dans cette
exposition vente a sorti les plus belles
photos de ses archives des documents
inédits et souvent surprenant enfin